plans are underway to remove an iconic
and controversial monument that has
stood in the former capital of the
Confederacy for 130 years
the statue of General Robert Ely in
Richmond Virginia has been a potent
symbol of the Civil War
the Confederacy and for many racism and
oppression
yesterday governor Ralph Northam who had
his own racial controversy over a
blackface photo announced that the
statue will be taken down the war heroes
of the Confederacy have long lined
Richmond's Monument Avenue the biggest
of all six stories high the statue of
General Robert Ely has stood since 1890
yes that statue has been there for a
long time but it was wrong then and it
is wrong now governor Ralph Northam said
Virginia could no longer honor a system
that supported slavery so I am directing
the Department of General Services to
remove the statue of Robert Ely as soon
as possible the monuments have become a
focal point of protests in the aftermath
of George Floyd's death Wednesday night
an image of Floyd was projected on the
base of the LEAs statue
we're glad like they're taking action in
there taking what we're saying seriously
so we're glad to hear that our voices
are being heard finally I hope that it's
not just performative you know I hope
that real change actually comes the
former capital of the Confederacy raised
the monument to General Lee 25 years
after the South lost the Civil War a
crowd of 150,000 came out in 1890 but
from the beginning there was no secret
about what the statue meant almost every
one of those 150,000 people waved
Confederate flags that day even General
Lee's descendant the Reverend Robert W
Lee the fourth
to the decision this statue is a symbol
of oppression and if it is a symbol it
becomes an idol and if it becomes an
idol I am convinced as a Christian that
the idols must be torn down supporters
of the monuments immediately protested
state senator Amanda chase a Republican
candidate for governor reacted on
Facebook it's all about shoving this
down people's thoughts and our and
erasing the history of the white people
and I think that's wrong but Richmond's
mayor levar Stoney wants all the
Confederate statues removed I don't
believe they should be on grand
boulevards like Monument Avenue I think
they should be found in museums and
cemeteries and battlefields the artist
Kehinde Wiley came face to face with
them for the first time a few years ago
what did you see I saw a spectacle that
felt dreadful to be in a black body
walking through the streets of Richmond
and to see something that signifies the
enslavement of your people that's a
little bit more heavy duty Wiley best
known for painting President Obama's
portrait answered with a monument of his
own a 27 foot high bronze sculpture of a
young black man on horseback unveiled in
December at Virginia's Museum of Fine
Arts in front of thousands who is this
man
well he's anyone and no one I think it
meant a lot to me to be able to say that
in the 21st century we as a society can
say yes to a monument to a young black
man in a hoodie
you want your statue to be speaking back
to those statues I want my statue to be
speaking back to the people looking at
those statues it makes sense to have
something exist on a monumental level
because this is a monumental
conversation that this country needs to
have the state of Virginia owns the land
the statue of General Lee stands on but
the other Confederate statues are all on
city property next month when a new law
allowing cities to decide the fate of
monuments
goes into effect mayor Stoney will move
to have them all taken down Gail yeah
you can never erase history Anthony but
I think people who support this decision
are saying it's never too late to do the
right thing
thank you very much I had bladder murder
duty a looks at the stories you'll go
ahead good no I was just gonna say I
wanted to mention the story the statue
of General Lee will be put into storage
Gail for the time being while they
decide where it's going to end up the
museum would be a nice place